john langler heather mills at the anchor
desk joe muller watching traffic nathan
talenbaum with the weather clicker and
there is the new home of the las vegas
bowl a legion stadium a blanket of cloud
cover but you're asking where is the
rain we've had some scattered light
sprinkles that's been about it you know
what it may be all we're going to get
but we have continuing chances now the
official temperature out of reed
international 45 humidity still at 68
percent a little bit of a breeze out of
the west northwest at five dew point
indicating there's no real issue with
the potential for big rain right now we
are 11 degrees warmer than 24 hours ago
we'll check your neighborhoods here in a
second winter storm warning expires this
afternoon for san bernardino county but
continues till tomorrow afternoon for
the sheep mountains that includes
i'm sorry the spring mountains that
includes mount charleston there's the
sheep mountains to the north lincoln
county also northwest arizona
southwestern utah in on the deal
the line of showers and thunderstorms
appears to kind of dwindle as it goes
across the desert and into southern
nevada we're not completely out of the
woods just yet and certainly southern
california is still getting hammered for
us looks like just scattered light rain
hour by hour a mixture of sprinkles
maybe some light rain will get you down
to 43 here in the next couple of hours
then turn it around close to 50 at noon
52 the afternoon high and then 48 with
still some sprinkles around